Now, when we look back at Galileo's data, we had this pattern
that we wanted to see emerging--this 1, 4, 9, 16.
These seem to be squares, perfect squares.
Now, one thing I should mention is an assumption we're making.
The assumption we're making when we do this experiment or just about any experiment
is that nature is repeatable.
By that I mean when we roll the ball for 1 unit of time,
if we actually role for 1 unit, the ball will go the exact same distance in all five of these trials.
The reason why these numbers aren't all identical
is because we either miss-timed or miss-measured the distance.
It's an error on our end.
It's an error on our end, not on nature's end.
To quantify the error on our end, how good we are at making these observations,
we've calculated this average deviation.
What this average deviation tells us is that
for each of these trials, each of these four different experiments,
we believe the true distance to be, well, for example, 1 ± 0.01 distance units--
whatever those distances were.
That means the true value here could have been between 0.99 and 1.01.
That means we believe that the minimum distance this ball actually rolled was 0.99
and the max was 1.01.
This is 1 - 0.01, and this is 1 + 0.01.
What would be the minimum and maximum possible true distances for this example?